[Musik]
das kurzzeit hey hey es gibt neuigkeiten
wir haben einen investor was einfach so
nicht ganz
ergebnis vier wochen zeit das heißt wir
müssen den lieferservice in einem monat
starten in einem monat soll das denn
wurzeln na ja er will sehen dass wir es
wirklich ernst meinen wir meinen es
ernst
deshalb brauchen wir auch mehr zeit zum
planen und so das schaffen wir nie im
leben in vier wochen so wollen wir am
meisten zeit na ja wir brauchen bestimmt
viel zeit zum ausbau der küche das
dauert mindestens drei bis vier wochen
wenn es gut läuft außerdem brauchen wir
noch ein paar wochen ein neues personal
einzustellen
das geht auch nicht so einfach die
müssen ja auch noch eingearbeitet werden
und du wirst musst du noch machen
ich erstelle die apple webseite und
überarbeitetem businessplan aber das
geht relativ schnell
es wird stressig ich weiß nicht ob
wieder schaffen
die arbeit im restaurant ist ja auch
noch da wir können nicht einfach
schließen können wir den termin nicht
verschieben
nein es gibt noch eine bedingung